while claiming publicly that there is
simply no Russia story and the
investigation by Robert Muller is a
witch-hunt
Donald Trump's lawyers are now privately
trying to negotiate a deal with Robert
Muller where Trump would be interviewed
by Muller but in exchange Muller would
agree to end the investigation
potentially within 60 days of the
interview it's so ridiculous that I can
barely even tell you what it is they
want with a straight face this is a
story that the Wall Street Journal broke
and what they're saying is that trumps
lawyers want to get things set up where
Muller would get an opportunity to
interview Trump maybe in a highly
restricted setting or where certain
things would be off-limits but then they
would have like for example 60 days to
either file charges or end the
investigation so far nobody has
commented about this idea to The Wall
Street Journal and I've said it before
and I'll say it again this is not how
innocent people behave right innocent
people don't try to put timelines for an
investigation to end innocent people
don't go in and ask for deals innocent
people don't assail the character and
integrity of the investigators if you
haven't done anything you don't need a
deal you don't ask for a deal you don't
make a deal and yeah I'm not talking
about the sort of plea bargain
industrial complex that happens at the
very low level that is terrible for poor
people and people who can't afford
lawyers I'm talking about at the level
on which Donald Trump is operating you
would say if you really wanted to show
your innocence that you look forward to
the investigation concluding that you
look forward to being cleared and that
in the meantime you will cooperate fully
and focus on your legislative agenda
that's not what Trump's team is asking
for what they're asking for is we'll
talk to you but you got to stop
investigating us even though the whole
point of the interview is figure out
whether you should be investigating
Trump you can't make a deal to determine
when a federal investigation into the
crimes you might have committed will end
and my hope is Robert Moeller would not
accept that and even the concept of
trying to make a deal before there are
charges is more proof that either Trump
understands nothing which i think is
probably true
and or that he has a really guilty mind
and I actually started thinking even
more cynically
and I started wondering is this a sort
of non offer as a first step to justify
firing Muller right laying the
groundwork to say look we offered him an
interview they didn't agree to it which
of course Muller can't agree to just end
the investigation in 60 days this thing
appears to just be getting started and
then using that as a possible
justification to fire Muller
why is everyone in such a rush though
right Benghazi took years and years and
Republicans didn't even get all the
investigations they wanted we had years
of oral sex investigations related to
Bill Clinton why shouldn't we be taking
our time on this one especially since we
now have a steady flow of what 17
indictments 15 16 indictments at this
point and I saw funny comment which is
that Trump is going through the stages
of grief first he denied no collusion
then it was anger tweeting in all caps
it's a witch-hunt attacking Muller and
now we're moving literally to bargaining
the third stage in the five stages of
grief which is I might be willing to be
interviewed by you if you end the
investigation if he's following this
path next would be depression which
according to some he's already well on
his way towards and at the end would be
acceptance and maybe at some point he's
going to have to accept that he's going
to have to be interviewed under oath
without a precondition that they wrap up
the investigation right after the
interview yeah but depression and
acceptance that doesn't really seem like
Trump no it doesn't it doesn't at all
although there's it seems like he is
sort of depressed all the time like he's
retreating into his own world and just
watching hours of beauty or whatever I
don't know yeah I think you think I mean
that the request is bogus yeah like what
could they offer Muller it's not like
you could just pay him off he's working
for the government after all yeah I
think that the big question will be
whether ultimately Trump is subpoenaed
formally at which Kay at which point his
legal team would have to come up with
legal reasons not to be interviewed by
Moeller and I don't know what that's
gonna happen but big picture people
don't seek out deals for totally made-up
hoaxes and witch hunts that have no
merit right they SiC seek out deals when
they are or think
might be chargeable with some kind of
crime today's program is brought to you
in part by futur which is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you can open up
the game on your phone in your web
browser you'll see a big range of
forecasts covering topics from politics
to sports and everything in between you
wager on predictions using fitters
in-game fake currency and you win more
of that fake currency every time your
predictions come true so if you say if
you like to talk to your friends that
you're very good at predicting what's
going to happen
show off your prediction skills improve
your forecasting ability I'm on food
tour myself you can find my account and
follow me by clicking the link in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube and this week on futur I pose
the question will another Trump cabinet
member leave by March 31st we've talked
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders and how
Trump is not pleased with her recently
but she's not a cabinet member will
another Trump cabinet member leave by
the end of this month what do you think
click the link in the description if
you're watching on YouTube place your
bets make your wagers with the in games
fake currency you can also browse the
politics category on food tour to wager
on other predictions and you can sign up
now at fut uur dot-com free available on
android iOS as well as in your web
browser check it out fut you you are
calm